постріл
в роботі помітний ефект відразу тобто
результат твоєї роботи Юрію 34 роки він
родом з Харківщини до повномасштабного
вторгнення хлопець виготовляв і
встановлював меблі після 24 лютого хотів
приєднатися до ЗСУ Але у військкоматах
відмовляли коли займався волонтерством
познайомився на блокпості з одним
військовим
який через час потім подзвонив і каже ти
ж там хотів потрапити створюється
бригада хартія якщо бажаєш ось тобі
контакти телефонуй я зателефонував
приїхав і лишився з ними Віталій
професійний військовий на службі з 2012
року воював в АТО у складі Нацгвардії А
нині він командир гаубичного дивізіону з
Юрієм його об'єднує Батьківщина
харківщина і бригада хартія я знайомий з
командиром бригади ще 16-го року коли
він був командиром батальйону Я навіть
не запитував яка посада буде Куди ми
йдемо Він запропонував Я його знаю тому
я знав що
далі ми не будемо займатися паперовою
роботою а будемо називатися бойовою
роботою тому я відразу пішов на хартії
хартія підрозділ який з’явився у перші
місяці повномасштабного вторгнення на
Харківщині тоді це було добровольче
формування територіальної громади
близько 200 добровольців здебільшого
цивільних вони стали одними з перших хто
вийшов на українсько-російський кордон у
Харківській області це
місце
перетинання державного кордону з
на кацапі а он уже український прапор
встановила Харків на цих кадрах Всеволод
Кожум'яку бізнесмена грарій
Мілу українського Форбс Один зі
найбагатших людей України у 2020 році
навесні 2022 Він створив хартію мені там
один товариш порадив ідею що можна так
зробити А я ж в армію в мене не освіти
немає нічого я там не можу бути
організаторами я можу бути там взяти
зброю піхотинців може бути якісним і
піти Там але я ж відчуваю що я можу
більше щось зробити От і за мною люди
які розглядали мене як якогось лідера Да
це було команда людей люди які в мене
працювали там і в охороні були і ті з
ким я спілкувався щось там з 14-го року
Ці хлопці підтримали мої друзі
бізнесмени мої друзі харків'яни активні
такі як Жадан наприклад там один
порадив в інший допоміг
оформити документи назву харті
запропонував письменник і музикант
Сергій Жадан підрозділ також підтримали
тенісисти Еліна Світоліна і Сергій
Стаховський та форма озброєння пальне
виплати бійцям спершу все це
фінансувалося за кошти Всеволода
Кожум'яка і його друзів бізнесменів
проте кожемяко не вважає хартію своєю
приватною армією Хоча вона діяла як
фактично
поефективності не гірше а я думаю що
може і краще от ніж приватна військова
компанія але тут же ж мова пройшла ішла
не про прибуток А про те щоби захищати
там рідне місто і рідну землю от тобто
люди були об'єднані
певною метою вони
пасіонарні Захисники вони
хотіли цього І вони мали певні професії
в цивільному житті якщо б війни не було
То вони
не брали в руки зброю розумієте тому
мабуть порівняння з приватною військовою
компанією воно не стовідсотково працює
хартія функціонувала як невелике але
самодостатньо формування після
звільнення Харківщини воювала на
Луганщині була єдиним добровольчим
підрозділом у бахмуті за словами
Кожум'яки його витрати на батальйон
сягали мільйонів доларів неможливо це
фінансувати без держави тому що ну це
дуже великі гроші Коли це там
місяць-два-три там півроку а коли вже
рік а ми проваливали вік рік як
добровольці то треба в якісь вже брати
рішення Тим більше що хлопців вже
виросли в реальних військових реальних
фахівців як наслідок навесні 2023 року
хартія стала частиною Гвардії наступу у
складі Нацгвардії нині це бригада що
формується її бійці проходять навчання
із злагодження долав підрозділу триває
набір обіцяють будь-якого цивільного
перетворити на професійного винищувача
воро га приходять різні люди
деяких дають воєнкомати цивільних деякі
переводяться з других частин тобто ну
взагалі дуже різний контингент ну
спостерігаючи за суміжниками то
дуже якби суттєвий результат в хартії
дуже багато приділяється уваги кожному
бійцю кожній людині тобто людина це
найцінніше що є
і
рівень підготовки хартії дуже великий ми
використовуємо
натовські стандарти по досвіду з інших
частин є дуже великий відмінності перше
це сама робота планування цієї роботи Ми
більше приділяємо уваги
спланувати це все Перше чим виконувати
завдання тому для мене це є раціональним
і правильним рішенням що я вибрав
підрозділ і цей шлях для себе далі
Агрохолдинг Всеволода кожемяко агротрейд
нині працює на 80-90 відсотків частина
підприємств холдингу пошкоджена деякі
досі перебувають в зоні бойових дій Утім
усе чим Він нині займається це хартія
формально кожемяка обіймає посаду
радника командувача Нацгвардії бізнесмен
каже Що відчуває відповідальність за
підрозділ який створив намагаюся
зберегти ту середовище яке було створено
хартією А це фактично середовище
патріотів е-е патрів патріотів
мотивованих бійців і патріотів
бізнесменів які їх підтримують і
підтримувати тут допомогу яку давали
хартія як добровольчому підрозділу на
уже бригаду Національної гвардії Я
ніколи не буваю задоволений як шофером
функціонує якщо формується бюрократія
дуже велика можливо знаєте я ж теж
сприймаю як бізнесмен в компанії навіть
великий там ви як у нас
рішення приймається дуже швидко і
втілюється вони дуже швидко але ми ж від
кого не залишимо тут
задіяно дуже багато державних установ і
це вимагає певної процедури і Звісно що
ми десь критикуємо з одного боку а з
іншого розуміємо що можливо в деяких
випадках
по іншому ніяк не вийде
і буде наказ командування її бійці
приєднаються до Контрнаступ Віталій
досвідчений військовий який приєднався
до бригади нещодавно готовий ділитися
знаннями і досвідом всі втомилися я
втомився але іншого виходу в нас немає
кістяк бригади хартія це добровольці які
звільняли харківщину серед них і Юрій
який встиг повоювати у Руській Лозовій
на Луганщині й у бахмуті зараз зайшов на
нашу територію руйнує наші домівки
вбиває наших людей
тобто дуже складно залишатися в Стороні
і дивитися просто на це
Утім хлопець цивільний в минулому житті
нині не уявляє себе поза армією